what we're going to do in this video is
try to break down the terminology and a
little bit of the math of health
insurance so the first question that you
might wonder is how much does an
insurance plan cost in many cases you
might have an employer who pays for all
or part of your insurance but in many
cases you have to get your own insurance
and so I'm going to focus on the second
case what I did is I went to my state's
insurance exchange and I just looked up
an indicative plan for a family of four
that makes a combined 100 thousand
dollars a year and this is just one of
the plans that I found I got rid of the
company's name and what it has here is
the monthly premium so whenever people
talk about premiums in insurance they're
talking about the amount that you have
to pay to get the insurance so this is
saying that you have to pay six hundred
twenty nine dollars and 51 cents a month
in order to get this insurance you might
also hear things in terms of annual
premiums and you might guess how to go
from a monthly to an annual annual
premium if you multiply this number six
hundred twenty nine dollars and fifty
one cents times twelve you're going to
get an annual premium of seven thousand
five hundred and fifty four dollars and
twelve cents so this is how much someone
would have to play pay likely you in
order to get this insurance and what
this is telling me on my exchange is
that this is actually after a pretty big
subsidy that I'm getting from the
federal and state government and most of
this is happening from the federal
government but we could talk about that
in future videos the big picture here is
if you want to know how much a policy
costs that's the premium this is how
much per month and this is how much per
year now the next thing that you are
very likely to see when getting a policy
is a term called a deductible and one
way to think about a deductible is this
is how much you will have to pay out of
your own pocket until the insurance
really starts to kick in so here we're
looking at actually two columns in
network and out-of-network in network
are doctors and health care providers
that the insurance company already has
put in their network they already have
some type of an arrangement with while
out of network they don't have an
arrangement with those parties so for
this insurer if you go in network you
can you would have to spend up to sixty
three hundred dollars on an individual
before the insurance really starts to
kick in so if you had to go and get some
type of a surgery that costs $6,000 even
if you've been paying the premium you
would have to pay $6,000 on top of the
premium in order to get that surgery if
that surgery on the other hand for just
one person let's say that surgery costs
ten thousand three hundred dollars well
in that situation you would have to pay
the first six thousand three hundred so
- six thousand three hundred which means
the insurance company would pay the
remainder it would pay the remaining
four thousand dollars and in that year
if you were to get other surgeries for
that individual let's say it's you it
would then be covered the insurance
company would pay above and beyond
anything above and beyond the sixty
three hundred dollars now you also have
a deductible for the entire family so
they're not just totaling what each
individual is spending they're also
totaling what the whole family is
spending so let's say I have a I have
four people in my family and over the
course of the year I've had two for each
of them
I have spent thirty 150 I'm just using
this as an example so each of them have
not gotten to their individual
deductible yet but in total my family of
four thirty 150 times four is twelve
thousand six hundred dollars after this
point even though no individual has
maxed out their deductible yet now the
insurance will also kick in now when
they talk about a drug deductible this
is a separate deductible for the drugs
so the one that I looked at before that
could be general procedures or certain
types of care you might need while this
right over here is specific to what you
might need for med
but it's the same idea if it's for any
one individual the first five hundred
dollars on medication in that year
they're gonna have to pay out of pocket
but then after that the insurance kicks
in and then once again one thousand
dollars for the entire family now
out-of-pocket maximum this says no
matter what
no individual an individual basis should
you have to put out more than seven
thousand eight hundred dollars for an
individual no matter what happens and no
more than fifteen thousand six hundred
dollars for an entire family so this is
real money here but it's saying that you
won't have to pay more than that out of
your actual pocket and then here the
maximum cost per prescription this is
the most that you will ever have to pay
to get a prescription so even if there's
some type of exotic drug that costs a
thousand dollars per prescription the
most that you would have to pay is five
hundred dollars per prescription for
that
now that we've dissected deductibles a
good bit another term that you are
likely to see is copay copay one way to
think about it is something that you pay
every time you go into that service so
for example a primary care visit this
says the first three visits are sixty
five dollar copay before the deductible
so this is saying even if you haven't
used up your $6,300 individual
deductible your primary care visits are
covered but every visit you have to pay
$65 and the reason why they call it
copay is that you and the insurance
company are paying that visit might cost
the insurance company another 150 200
250 dollars but you're paying $65 on
every visit so the insurance company the
insurance is kicking in even before the
deductible has been reached
now specialist visits these if you go to
specialist doctors like a cardiologist
or a Rheumatologist or a dermatologist
these co-pays only kick in after the
deductible so what that means is before
you reach your deductible ceiling you're
going to pay what
it costs out of pocket so if that
specialist visit costs $500 you're going
to pay $500 but once you've reached your
deductible then every visit after that
is going to cost $95 is what you would
contribute and then the insurance
company would pay the rest now the last
term I'm going to introduce into this
video is that of coinsurance so what
this is telling us right here they're
telling us how we are covered for
various drugs so for example if it's a
generic drug these are things that are
off patent then you pay $18 after you
have reached your deductible so no
matter what the drug cost after you've
reached a deductible every prescription
you pay $18
now these tier 2 drugs and I'm not gonna
go into detail about this but these are
drugs that are tend to still be on
patent and they tend to be more
expensive what this coinsurance is
telling us is you're going to pay the
drugs out-of-pocket until you reach your
deductible for this insurance plan and
then after you've reached a deductible
you're gonna pay 40% of the cost so
whenever someone talks about coinsurance
that means that you are splitting the
cost with the insurance company at that
point and it's usually specified as a
percentage so the 40% is what you would
pay for that drug so if let's say it's
$100 a month you would pay 40% of that
so $40 and you would only get the 60
percent subsidy from the insurance
company after your drug deductible has
been reached so I will leave you there
I've already introduced a lot of ideas
to you but hopefully that will already
start to help you dissect how insurance
plans work